Hello, my name is Christina Ladas and I'm going to have a conversation
with Alexandria Economou for Visible Lives an
oral history project at the New York Public Library. It is February
8th, 2015 and this is being recorded in my studio
in Muttontown, Long Island, New York.
Hi, Alexandria.  Hi, Christina.  Tell me
about your earliest memories.
Well, I grew up in Queens and I spent a lot of time with my grandparents
when- while my mom was working.
You know that was a very happy time for me. Uh, but there was
also always blood tests and doctors' appointments or
something medical going on. I- you know, for me, my
earliest memories are more of a stream of consciousness. "um" It's very
Hard for me to separate out single events. It's
become almost like a giant snowball.
I can no longer see the individual snowflakes... Interesting
Who do you trust or believe in then? Uh, at this time
I didn't trust or believe in anybody. Um,
I was more like a wild animal, fighting for my life, fighting to survive
while I was going through different medical situations.
Can you talk about your disability?
I had a kidney transplant when I was a baby
and many other complications through the years. I've had
many orthopedic surgeries on my legs. I use a wheelchair,
have low vision, and learning disabilities.
What were you most afraid of when you were little? The so-called biggest monster under your
bed?
Well, actually, my monster didn't live under my bed. It was as big
as a hospital. Actually it was the hospital and, uh, the
entrance doors reminded me of a giant mouth.
You were the only disabled student in your school from kindergarten to third grade. What was that like?
Well, actually the laws for inclusion that
allowed me to be in a school for able-bodied students actually
excluded me, personally. "um"... How?
It was 100% inaccessible; you know, it was an old building,
there were stairs everywhere. "um" My mother and custodians had to
carry me in in my wheelchair and I, you know, I wasn't allowed to
move around the building because of safety reasons. "uh"
You know I remained in a classroom until the end of the day when they carried me out.
"um" I didn't really learn anything. Mainly,
you know, I guess you could say I learned about was
isolation and loneliness... In fourth grade you went to a different
school.
Can you talk about that?
In fourth grade, I went to a school where the
other students had, uh, physical disabilities or were medically
fragile and for the first time there was more of my kind.
Um, you know, I wasn't the only one. And actually
compared to some of the students, I was more able-bodied.
"um" You know, no longer
needing to be carried out during a fire drill. "um" I was actually
able to push the wheelchairs of other students and that was very empowering.
[paper shuffling]
I know that horses are central in your life,
How did that come about? "uh" When I was about eight years old my family
found theraputic horseback riding. Um, you know,
we had to get doctors to sign papers and
Just OK different things and have an evaluation at the barn.
"um" The first time I actually rode, I screamed and cried the whole time.
And I think that was because it was the first time that I was
ever really out of my wheelchair, moving, and that was terrifying.
but it actually, it didn't last long. "um"
You know, knowing that every Sunday I would be with horses. It was
something to look forward to... Why?
Because, um, horses, they didn't judge me or
ignore me they just accepted me. And soon "uh"
uh, horses and riding it became the center of my life and
everything else got in my way and it kept me away from the barn... What
was the prospect of graduation and going to college like?
Graduation and college was terrifying and surreal.
"uh" You know when you're when you go to a
school, that is "100" percent accessible and
is able to accommodate your needs. "um" The idea of
having to leave that safe place was just so scary. You know I wasn't
sure how I was going to fit into college, if I could do it, you know, I was still
recovering from major surgery. So it was just all very scary.
What were you like at this point? What did you trust or believe in?
Well at this time, uh, my horseback riding, um, actually
included competition
And, actually I had.
Taken a grand champion in my division at the Hampton Classic
only a week before starting college. And, uh, you know, on that first
day rolling into a classroom of "30" staring
students, you know, where I was the only, uh, wheelchair in the
room was a little, I was a little
unsure, but, uh, then I was thinking to myself, you know, I'm the only grand champion
in the room and that was cool. "um"
It was exciting. "um" "uh" You know it was exciting because I actually
started to believe in myself and I was starting to connect
to a definite spirituality.
Why was it exciting?... "um" Because I was able to see
the possibility "uh" you know I wasn't, I was able
to start seeing myself as a whole. "uh" You know not just
broken bits of this and that.  You're pursuing an
interesting career.
Can you talk about it?
Yes. I am studying animal-assisted therapy
working with dogs on Long Island and horses in Tucson.
. "uh"
My plan/goal is to work with kids who have physical
disabilities, uh, that have a similar journey to my own
because I bring an interesting perspective to it and, uh, you know these
animals have always been drawn to me
and I feel they can help, uh, people with
disabilities come out of their dark hiding place.
I know that you are a creative person. Tell me about that.
.
Well I'm a Reiki Master, uh, I'm a potter. You know
I work in the old way, meaning alternate firing. I
just love having my hands in the clay. I think that's because, uh,
clay holds ancient knowledge and this is something that our ancestors
knew. Um,
I'm a poet and I love performance.
I make jewelry and amulets for musicians.
You've been through so much. What makes you keep going?
Well, I would have to say it's possibility. Uhm...
and
hope, you know that's the last thing that, uh, people have to
hold onto, and I would say that doctors should never
forget that. And, you have to have hope.
Uhm, and you know, as I got older
I figured out that, uh, disability doesn't define you. It's
just part of who you are.
It's, it's part of me as a whole.  It's not separate from me.
.
What challenge have you conquered? Hmm, I would have to say
fear, um, because fear is my biggest
opponent in my existence.
I, you know, it's like flying against the wind or
endless falling into the black hole. You know, with nothing to grab
onto, um. But you know every time that I am able to
pull myself back into the light, uh, it's just
another, another victory for me. But you know
this warrior spirit here, it knows that it's not the last battle.
There will always be something coming up, some sort of fear. What are you most proud
of? I would have to say, getting out of my
wheelchair, which is hard. Getting into my saddle, which
is even harder. You know, uh, the amazing horse people
that I work with have to be really creative at times to help
me get into my saddle to ride, and they've been
so creative at times. I have a whole team working with me you, uh
know and working with a difficult horse, and then all of a
sudden just everything falls into place. It comes together so nicely.
.
What message do you want a listener to keep?
People are faceted like gemstones.  Turn almost
any one and the light will catch on
something beautiful, or unexpected. Don't hate
us, uh, you know. Don't break our hearts for no reason. Don't pity us.
Just give us a chance. Thank you
Alexandria. Thank you.